[Music]  my favorite moments are often times at  the premiere because I get to see  everybody all in one place those times  we get to like be with each other and  really understand the work that you've  been doing it's emotional personally for  all of us and also for movie it's very  personal  I just love playing my character so much  and I think that she's still  misunderstood the people are starting to  understand her a little bit more I've  had a few quiet moments with Downey he's  always just really been such a wonderful  mentor in a lot of ways and I've really  kind of said to myself don't forget this  the whole process been really  celebratory you know it's one that I  just kind of still can't believe that it  has happened there's a lot of pathos in  these last two that I just don't think  you see in superhero movies this is the  one I'm most excited to see this last  one I haven't really haven't had a bad  trip yet I'm just I'm super grateful